no victory in court today for a former
politician accused of killing a
journalist the eight news now
investigators have been following the
case against Robert Tullis very closely
Vanessa Murphy with the latest from the
Regional Justice Center in downtown Las
Vegas
the request from Robert tell us to get a
new judge denied this while the former
politician continues to represent
himself in his murder case she spent
about 40 minutes or so badgering me
harassing me and trying to embarrass me
into withdrawing my request for
self-representation Robert Ellis in
court Thursday the former Clark County
public administrator is accused of
killing investigative reporter Jeff
gearman last September after gearman
exposed issues under the leadership of
Telus Telus now arguing Judge Michelle
Levitt should be kicked off his case
accusing me of playing games
accusing me of being a fool here's a
couple of clips from that February
hearing he's referring to it's almost
always more wise to be represented by
Council not playing games
very very serious you weren't charged
with first degree murder I mean you're
facing life without the possibility of
parole I would think that you would take
it a little more serious chief judge
Jerry Weiss says he agrees it's
generally a bad idea for a defendant to
represent themselves he says judge
Levitt was just doing her job and she's
staying on the case you're doing a
criminal cases for a long long time
before heading back to jail tell us with
a plea for the media and if they can
contact me after this hearing anytime
after 2 pm please since we've already
interviewed Robert Tellis previously
twice in jail at this time we are not
requesting another interview today we've
heard enough from him in court reporting
in downtown Las Vegas at the Regional
Justice Center Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
a jury trial is scheduled for November
to watch those previous interviews with
Robert tell us you can head to our
website at 8newsnow.com